hello and welcome to this video playing
a legend that a title player it doesn't
have any information I think you had no
info okay it's doing night g2 is seven
hi funky line the what's a chord the
cozy a variation right let's see him I
think this is sometimes given as it
would reply to the immediate energy to
e7 we'll see what happens i think they
mostly played d6 nowadays in this
position no no it looks comfortable for
white may not not like a brilliant but
it's a comfortable position g6 okay hmm
there's some way to now probably not i
mean the dark squares are weakened I
just wondered if there is some way to
potentially exploit it like Knight to f6
would be made but yeah quite clearly not
an easily playable move so it says
something to do about this I wonder
I don't know not very familiar with this
kind of position okay I expected the
other recapture opinions centralized to
catch up a little bit timewise okay so
Queen d2 was very night see forms maybe
go here then yeah for Luke 81 just
centralizing I went with this 95 and c3e
to blunt that Bishop a little bit from
Giselle that the bishop is not having so
much fun on the diagonal so what's he
doing here Knight f6 maybe maybe
slightly better position right
exploiting this rook clean issue on the
D file okay so what's the deal I can
take form for a slight advantage queen
bee three years old so interesting maybe
it's got Queen f6 okay so probably
probably taking then okay it's probably
not even a slight advantage ookie ookie
8 Bishop 36 you can even play Queen d6
because of my week back rank that's
funky okay so then it's really
absolutely nothing
now even that is possible even that is
possible check
yeah just quite equal
mmm not the most exciting game ever yeah
but okay taking on d6 what's the mistake
which leads to which leads to this
position
yeah there's really nothing I can do I
mean I can weaken myself a little bit
maybe it tempt him to do something but
it's probably not happening Jim still
equal route before can you do roop t5
that's probably I wouldn't I don't want
to take then probably root leaf or check
I hope you're five slightly annoying him
some much going on
check check check
draw is still a very heavy favorite in
this position check my pawn structure is
a bit worse but shouldn't be shouldn't
be so um a big deal
I might still get in trouble him cook a
space and stuff Joe narrating looks is
always a bit tricky in the scanned in
this position the rook ending is just a
dead draw yeah maybe I should have just
done that this might this might be this
might become tricky check
mm-hmm this is actually very tricky time
morning
now King be five let's probably still a
draw yeah it is still a draw can I win
somehow is that somehow an idea somewhat
possible probably not it's no way to win
run around yeah I shouldn't have gone to
to think in pollinating this looked
somewhat critical yeah I mean I can Oh
Kim Chang Jack can just say I can also
just go here probably my erupted III mmm
yeah if i play whoopty for the first
place i probably should trade rooks I
mean something like this is just equal
it's got the better pawn structure but
it doesn't really matter much hmm yeah
that was a bit lame I i think this Jack
and thought here I would actually get a
little something OES got Queenie 6 which
overlooked a week back rank oh okay yeah
i'll give it here um this is just
totally dead i have to play a queen move
him to get e 6 as a possible idea this
would have been a lot more testing
probably still it's equal something like
this e 6f 6 sort the engine gifts but
this is better right f5 okay yeah but
here also rather be white with black
having a weekend king position yeah and
yeah if I'm a little bit better but the
whole idea was flawed due to Queenie 6m
because
cannot take now it's made check hmm yeah
so I probably just played the opening
for to check and if I to a simple way
and here we're just sitting in an equal
ending I wonder if there was something
in the key appointing it really found a
check awkward check check check I won't
ever overlooked something I should have
played a for this is this is so yeah
pretty much forgot that he can do that
and here not sure probably it's still a
draw do this I should be a draw I think
here it's the Deaf hits here is
definitely a check no the best that you
can do is like this and I'm just taking
a couple of times and here it's simply
nothing going on which is just as dead
yeah that wasn't too exciting I probably
should have played queen bee three year
and yeah keep keep a little bit more
tension on the board the way it was
played out there was simply nothing ever
for white but I didn't see them this
defense is based on them big back rank
okay well thanks for watching